GEORGIA LAW.
>> GOT IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> BRITAIN IS IN A WEEK OF
NATIONAL MOURNING HONORING THE
LIFE OF PRINCE PHILIP.
QUEEN ELIZABETH'S HUSBAND OF 73
YEARS DIED ON FRIDAY.
THAT'S TWO MONTHS BEFORE HIS
100th BIRTHDAY.
HIS BIRTHDAY WOULD HAVE BEEN
JUNE 10th.
OVER THE WEEKEND, MEMBERS OF THE
ROYAL FAMILY TALKED ABOUT
PHILLIP AND HIS LOSS.
HOLLY WILLIAMS IS OUTSIDE
WINDSOR CASTLE WHERE THE QUEEN
IS IN SECLUSION.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING ABOUT THE
PRINCE'S FUNERAL THAT'S
SCHEDULED I UNDERSTAND FOR THIS
SATURDAY.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING.
WELL, PRINCE PHILIP'S FUNERAL
WILL BE HELD HERE AT WINDSOR
CASTLE.
INSIDE ST. GEORGE'S CHAPEL.
THAT'S WHERE HARRY AND MEGHAN
WERE MARRIED.
THE FUNERAL WILL BE TELEVISED,
BUT BECAUSE OF COVID
RESTRICTIONS, ONLY 30 PEOPLE CAN
ATTEND.
ACROSS THE UNITED KINGDOM FROM
SCOTLAND TO ENGLAND --
>> FIRE!
>> Reporter: AND AT SEA THEY
REMEMBERED PRINCE PHILIP ON
SATURDAY WITH A 41-GUNMEN
SALUTE.
A FITTING TRIBUTE FOR A MAN WHO
SERVED THIS COUNTRY AS CONSORT
TO THE QUEEN FOR MORE THAN SEVEN
DECADES AND WAS A MILITARY HERO
IN THE SECOND WORLD WAR.
>> MY FAMILY AND I MISS MY
FATHER ENORMOUSLY.
>> Reporter: HIS ELDEST SON AND
HEIR TO THE THRONE, PRINCE
CHARLES, CELEBRATED PHILIP'S
LIFE.
>> MY DEAR PAPA WAS A VERY
SPECIAL PERSON WHO I THINK ABOVE
ALL ELSE WOULD HAVE BEEN AMAZED
BY THE REACTION AND THE TOUCHING
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN SAID ABOUT
HIM.
[ CHEERS ]
>> Reporter: FOR DECADES, PHILIP
WAS REGARDED BY SOME AS THE
POWER BEHIND THE THRONE.
WESLEY KERR, A FORMER ROYAL
CORRESPONDENT, TOLD US A
GENERATIONAL SHIFT HAS ALREADY
TAKEN PLACE INSIDE THE MONARCHY.
>> THE QUEEN HAS BEEN DOING
QUITE A LOT LESS ANYWAY, EVEN
PRE-COVID.
AND ALL THE BIG FOREIGN TOURS
ARE DONE BY CHARLES AND WILLIAM.
THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING FOR SOME
TIME.
>> Reporter: BUT THE YOUNGER
MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE OF WINDSOR
ARE A MORE COMPLICATED LOT THAN
THE QUEEN AND HER HUSBAND WHO
APPEARED HAPPILY MARRIED FOR 73
YEARS.
PRINCE ANDREW SPOKE OF HIS
FAMILY'S LOSS, THE FIRST TIME
HE'S BEEN HEARD FROM SINCE THE
JEFFREY EPSTEIN SCANDAL PUT AN
END TO HIS PUBLIC ROLE AS A
ROYAL.
>> AND I FEEL VERY SORRY AND
SUPPORTIVE OF MY MOTHER WHO'S
FEELING IT I THINK PROBABLY MORE
THAN EVERYBODY ELSE.
>> Reporter: AND WHILE MEGHAN'S
PREGNANCY MEANS SHE WON'T ATTEND
THE FUNERAL, HARRY WILL BE THERE
JUST WEEKS AFTER THE COUPLE'S
BOMBSHELL INTERVIEW WITH OPRAH
AND ALLEGATIONS OF RACISM WITHIN
THE ROYAL FAMILY.
>> I THINK HARRY WILL BE GREETED
AS A VERY, VERY CLOSE FAMILY
MEMBER BY HIS GRANNY, BY HIS
FATHER, BY HIS BROTHER AND BY
HIS COUSINS.
IN A FAMILY, THERE ARE DISPUTES,
BUT I THINK TOGETHERNESS
ESPECIALLY AT THE FUNERAL OF A
GREAT PATRIARCH I THINK IS GOING
TO BE THE KEY THING.
>> Reporter: WE UNDERSTAND THAT
PRINCE HARRY IS ALREADY HERE IN
THE UK.
ONE PERSON WHO WE HAVE NOT SEEN
SINCE PRINCE PHILIP'S DEATH IS
HIS WIFE, THE QUEEN.
TONY?
>> HOLLY WILLIAMS IN WINDSOR,
ENGLAND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'D LOVE TO BE A FLY ON THE WALL
WHEN HARRY WALKS IN AND THE
FAMILY GREETS HIM.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY IT'S
STILL FAMILY.
ANDREW SAYING THE DEATH OF HIS
DAD LEAVES A HUGE VOID IN HIS
MOM'S LIFE.
AND THE FAMILY, I UNDERSTAND, IS
DESCRIBING IT AS A MIRACLE THAT
HE DIED PEACEFULLY IN HIS SLEEP,
YOU KNOW.
EVERYBODY THOUGHT AFTER HE LEFT
THE HOSPITAL THAT MAYBE THERE
WAS A RALLY THERE.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS WONDERING --
HOW IT ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
I SAW OVER THE WEEKEND DIFFERENT
INTERVIEWS, AND THEY DESCRIBED
IT AS A MIRACLE.
I THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY,
WHAT A BEAUTIFUL WAY TO GO WHEN
YOUR TIME COMES.
THAT YOU'RE VERY OLD AND THAT
YOU CAN DIE PEACEFULLY IN YOUR
SLEEP SURROUNDED BY PEOPLE THAT
CARE ABOUT YOU.
>> HE WENT WHERE HE WANTED TO